DON DODGE: We have a great panel
today to help us answer
some of these questions.
First, Jessica Livingston.
Jessica started in investment
banking and then was a
co-founder of Y Combinator,
and has written a book--
several books, I think-- but the
one that I read, "Founders
at Work." And Paul Graham, the
other founder of Y Combinator,
made one of the best decisions
in his life when he proposed
to marry Jessica.
So they're husband and wife.
Next to Jessica,
Naval Ravikant.
Naval is the founder
of Angel List.
I'm sure you all know
about Angel List.
But he's also an entrepreneur
before that.
He co-founded several companies
before that--
Genoa, Epinions.
You probably have heard
of Epinions.
And he's also a co-author
of "Venture Hacks."
And next to Naval, Heidi Roizen,
a longtime friend.
Heidi is also an entrepreneur
and founder.
She co-founded T/Maker
back in the PC era.
And she was a venture capitalist
at SoftBank, one of
the hottest venture capital
firms at the time, and is now
at Draper Fisher Jurvetson,
and she's also
a lecturer at Stanford.
So very accomplished panel.
So the way we run this, this
session is for you.
So there are two mics here, and
we want you to come up and
ask questions throughout.
So I'm going to start with
some questions to get it
going, but at any point, come up
to the mic, I'll recognize
you, and you can ask
your question.
Typically, over half
of this session is
questions from the audience.
So start thinking about your
questions, line up at the mic,
and we'll get as
many as we can.
I'll start with a few
questions here.
So Jessica, Y Combinator, it's
the first and largest
incubator ever.
How many companies apply to Y
Combinator now, and how many
do you accept?
JESSICA LIVINGSTON:
Can you hear me?
Lately, like the last
application process we had for
the summer batch, I think we got
about 2,500 applications,
and this summer's batch
is 52 startups.
DON DODGE: 52 out of 2,500.
JESSICA LIVINGSTON: Out
of 2,500, yeah.
DON DODGE: So that's like 2%.
JESSICA LIVINGSTON:
It's pretty low.
DON DODGE: Cool.
That's harder than Harvard
to get into Y Combinator.
Probably better, too.
How do you decide which
companies to accept?
JESSICA LIVINGSTON: Well we have
10-minute interviews, so
it's a big challenge to
choose the startups.
And for those of you who don't
know, we conduct the
interviews back to back all day
long, and then we contact
the founders that night to say
whether we'd like to fund them
or not, so they find
out that very day.
So in the 10 minutes,
what do we do?
We have three different tracks
of Y Combinator partners doing
the interviews.
So I'm in a room with Paul and
Robert and Trevor, the
original founders, and they're
all technical.
I'm not technical.
And so I let them evaluate the
technology and evaluate
whether the founders are good at
programming, which is very
hard to tell.
But you can sometimes base it
on what they've built if
they've built something already,
or if they, in their
application, have built
something in the past, we take
a long look at that in the
application process.
What I am looking at
specifically in interviews, I
sort of block out all the other
stuff and I'm looking at
the co-founder dynamic and the
personalities of the founders.
Have they thought deeply about
what their startup idea, the
area that it's in?
Do they seem excited about
it, believe it or not?
Do they get along?
Are they interrupting
each other?
That's a bad sign.
Different things like that.
It's sort of hard to describe.
And then literally after the
10 minutes, the four of us
say, OK, should we
fund them or not?
And sometimes it's very clear
and we all say absolutely
because we're excited about
the idea and the people.
Sometimes we have to talk about
it for a few minutes,
but it's never more than
a few minutes.
DON DODGE: So in 10 minutes, you
can decide whether this is
a company you're going
to invest in or not.
JESSICA LIVINGSTON: Yeah.
It seems pretty crazy, and
sometimes we're wrong.
But when we first started Y
Combinator in 2005, we had
half an hour interviews.
Of course, we were only
interviewing 25 startups at
that point.
But we realized that we really
did have a sense after the
first few minutes and a lot
of the time was wasted.
So we make it 10 minutes so we
can talk to more groups.
DON DODGE: Cool.
So Heidi, you're in the venture
capital business and
you fund companies.
How do you decide who to fund
and who not to fund?
HEIDI ROIZEN: Well, a lot of the
work gets done before we
ever meet face to face because
I think for every venture
capital firm, there are areas
that we are knowledgeable in
and there are areas we're
not knowledgeable in.
It doesn't make a lot of sense
for us to try to make an
investment in an area that we
don't know anything about.
I think that's pretty true
of most venture firms.
They'll pick practice areas that
they're interested in.
We look at a lot of deals
that come in.
We get together every Monday,
the partners, and we discuss
things that we've seen or things
we've heard about.
Obviously, we're batting things
around on email a lot.
If you think about when we're
in a partner meeting,
collectively among us, we sit
on close to 100 boards, so
it's a very interesting group
of people because we're in
there with about 100 company
data points in real time in
our heads, presuming we're
paying attention to the
companies we're actually already
invested in, which
isn't always true of all VCs.
But we have a lot
of data points.
And so part of looking at
funding-- and by the way, I
was an entrepreneur.
I spent six months on the road
my first time out trying to
raise money.
No one would fund us.
We self-funded, we
bootstrappped, and we funded
in my very most favorite way to
be funded way, which is not
represented by any of us up
here, which is we actually got
customers to buy our product.
It's this really cool way to
get funding because it's
non-dilutive and you learn
something and it validates
your business proposition.
So it's cool at many levels,
and that's how we did it.
And so we only raised our first
round six years after we
started the company, and we were
already about $4 million
in revenue and profitable when
we did, which really changes
your dynamics in terms of what
you can negotiate with.
So I give you all that to say,
I've been on your side of the
table, and I've been on
my side of the table.
I've been on both sides the
table and it is a relatively
random process.
So if you're sitting there
thinking, this sounds
ridiculous.
How could you possibly make a
decision in 10 minutes, which
I completely agree.
We do the same thing.
How could you read a one pager
and know whether you're going
to invest or not?
I don't know.
It's a pretty crazy system,
but that's how the vast
majority of the venture
capitalists I know do it.
It's a lot about gut and feel
and pattern recognition and
pattern and sensing something
about the team and the mission
they're on, and it's very hard
to articulate, which is why
also venture is very much a
small team, a business.
It's also why you'll take 50
meetings and you'll get 50
different answers.
And when you ask VCs for
feedback, you'll get
diametrically opposed views,
and that doesn't matter.
You just go out and kiss
a bunch of frogs, and
eventually, you will
find one, I think.
If you believe in your idea and
you've got a good idea,
you will find one.
But it is a lengthy process
and don't think that the
people on the other side of the
table from you have some
magic thing.
And I'll just close
by saying this.
I know some VCs who've tried
over time to quantify this.
In fact, I know this big
initiative going on that one
person's doing who's super smart
and is trying to do this
thing about, if you have these
degrees from these places and
you worked at these places, and
in fact, if you dropped
out before you finish-- because
that's the current
lore is it's better to drop out
from Harvard or Stanford
than it is to actually finish
in any one of those places.
So he's actually trying to do
this analysis and say, can I
figure out which ones
are going to be the
best based on analysis?
And just so far, every
one of those
initiatives has largely failed.
So it really is all about
reading, being able to get
your point across well enough
that you intrigue someone
enough to take that
first meeting.
It's not about getting all the
way to the finish line.
It's about intriguing us enough
so we'll take the
meeting, and then it's about
knowing how to make that 10
minutes really count.
DON DODGE: Right.
We have questions
in the audience.
Let's start here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
It's a great panel.
I was recently at a meeting of
VCs where I met somebody who
sort of criticized the idea of
all these different startup
incubators coming up.
He though, well, they're forced
into a three-month
program, and at the end of the
time, they have to show that
they're on a hockey stick sort
of curve in terms of the
revenue, and if they don't
do it, then that's it.
You don't really get anywhere.
So his criticism was that
these incubators force
businesses to sort of develop
a certain way, and he didn't
think that was good.
So I was wondering what your
thoughts are on the whole idea
of all these different
incubators
coming up in general.
JESSICA LIVINGSTON: I assume
that's for me.
Well, when we started Y
Combinator, I can promise you
we did not expect there
to be so many people
doing what we do.
So I don't know.
I don't really have a comment
on if it's good or bad.
But in terms of our startups,
over this three month period,
we're working very closely with
them to help prepare them
for Demo Day, which is when
there's a room filled with
investors, 400 investors, to
come and see their two and a
half minute pitches.
And again, the goal is to just
create an interest and
hopefully get a meeting.
And we think that that's a great
idea because it's such
an efficient way for investors
to spend a couple hours of
their time and see 40 or
50 companies at once.
It's great if there's a
hockey stick curve.
It's great if after three
months, you have this major
growth rate because investors
love that.
But it's certainly not true
for everyone, and it's
certainly not true that every
single startup raises tons of
money right after Demo Day.
Some of them raise Series A,
some of them raise a few
hundred thousand dollars and
get back to working on the
product, and then six months
to a year later, we'll help
them go out and they'll
raise funding then.
AUDIENCE: So do you think having
all these incubators is
a good thing?
NAVAL RAVIKANT: So the
accelerators are there--
I actually don't like calling
them incubators, so I'm just
going to switch the terminology
if someone doesn't
mind, because they're not really
incubating little eggs
and hatching them.
I just find that's like a
demeaning nomenclature.
The accelerators serve three
incredibly important
functions, just like schools
do, just like MIT does or
Harvard does.
One is they filter.
So they help go through all the
noise and say, these are
the people worth looking at
before they might have a
product or before they
might have traction.
So that 10 minute interview
that Jessica and Paul and
Robert and Trevor do, people pay
enormous amounts of money
for the output from those 10
minute interviews, so that's
very important function.
The second thing that the
accelerators do is they do the
education function.
Part of that might be, look,
here's how you raise money.
That's kind of an obvious
question people
are going to ask.
And the third thing they do is
they build an incredible
alumni network that pulls
resources, educates the
entrepreneurs, unionizes their
power a little bit, and
standardizes the things that
they might have had to do one
off or ad hoc.
So these are very valuable
functions, and without the
accelerators today,
I don't think the
angels could function.
There would be too may deals out
there to look at, and they
wouldn't know what to look
at and what not to.
And without the angels out
there, I don't think the VCs
could function.
The VCs are using the angels
for signals, and the angels
are using the accelerators
for signals.
So like it or not, they're a
part of the ecosystem that's
here to stay.
But just like there are lots of
angels and there are good
ones and bad ones, and just like
there are lots of VCs and
there are successful ones and
failed ones, there are lots of
accelerators, and there's the
cream of the crop, and there's
the not so good.
So they're an important part of
infrastructure that's not
going away.
I would say that today, probably
half of the companies
that we feature on Angel List
have come through some
accelerator or another, and we
count that signal in as to
which accelerator they came
from and who they got
associated from that accelerator
and what kind of
financing they did afterwards
as an input signal.
Everyone in this business is
looking at tons of noise and
trying to extract signals.
And it is through that
pattern matching.
And to the point earlier, you
cannot systematize that.
You can't automate it.
Think about the combinatorics
of human DNA.
There's six billion, seven
billion people on this planet.
No two are even vaguely
similar if
you get to know them.
And companies at this stage
are just combinations of
individuals, so they're
even more unique.
So you need all these human
filters who are constantly
quickly assessing everyone to
figure out who gets to make it
to the next stage.
Like it or not, that's
the way it works.
HEIDI ROIZEN: I want to add one
thing because I've heard
that same thing.
If you tell people that they
have to solve a problem with
three months and $50,000, you're
only going to solve
easy problems, is
the complaint.
And number one, I'm a huge fan
of accelerators and of angel
financing because I think
that they do fill--
yes, there are problems you can
actually solve in three
months with $50,000, but there
are also problems you can kind
of take your first whack at it
with three months and $50,000
and show progression, even if
it's not user metrics because
you don't get there.
At the other end of the
spectrum, there are things,
like I know Singularity is
trying to mount something
where they're trying to solve
really big problems.
They're trying to stake out the
area where they say, we're
actually going to be the
accelerator that solves really
big problems that take
a long time.
The problem with really big
problems that take a long time
is the funding mechanisms of
both, I think accelerators and
angel investors, they're not
life cycle financing for
really big problems, which is
why you have a whole food
chain of people, including
venture capitalists, all the
way up through investment
bankers and ultimately the
public markets-- which there
are periods of time where
public markets actually allow
non-profitable companies to go
public, which is another
way of getting funding.
So I think there's that whole
food chain there.
I think you have to know--
and this is a really important
thing for everybody, not just
for accelerator or angels
or whatever--
you have to know what you're
trying to do and what kind of
financing is appropriate for
you, because you can bang your
head against the wall all day
going to people who are just
the wrong people to fund you.
And people often will take
meetings, especially if you've
got something interesting,
because they like to get
educated, and you do not want
to spend all your time
educating the population.
So it's important to
understand that.
I do want to say there's
a really great book.
It is about venture financing,
but it also covers the other
areas, by these two guys, Brad
Feld and Jason Mendelson, who
are partners at Foundry Group,
and it's called "Venture
Deals, How to be Smarter Than
Your Venture Capitalist," or
something like that.
And actually, it does a really
nice job laying out the
landscape of financing and how
financing works, which I think
is super critical.
If you're going to take money
from anyone, you should know
what the whole end to
end life cycle looks
like for outside capital.
DON DODGE: OK, great.
We have to on to the
next question.
AUDIENCE: All right.
My name's Jake.
I'm from Fargo, North Dakota.
Fargo's a lot different
than California.
HEIDI ROIZEN: I was on the board
at Great Plains for five
years, so I've been to Fargo
many, many times.
AUDIENCE: And you know
Doug then, I suppose.
So we only have one venture
capitalist group in all of
North Dakota that I know of, I
believe, and they're in Fargo.
When I was 20, I started
a company doing mobile
development, all the
way through 23
now, still doing that.
But we did it one of those
unique ways where we didn't
raise money, we just built a
company that sold stuff and
made money.
And one of the things I did
realize, though, is I always
thought venture capital is a bad
idea, this is a bad idea.
But I realized that there are
problems that we'd like to
solve that are bigger than what
we have for resources.
And so in Fargo, those guys are
doing some of that, but
how do we inspire the idea
of venture capitalism--
there's some angel,
but it's totally
different than out here.
How do we bring that to Fargo?
And if not that right now, how
can people who are where we're
at work with you guys to
build something great?
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Well first,
you've got to make a lot of
money, get rich and then spend
it in North Dakota.
AUDIENCE: Working on it.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Or you need to
make so much money that your
neighbors get jealous and then
want to invest in startups.
That's kind of how it works.
So if you look at Estonia,
it's a small country that
punches outside of its weight
in the startup industry
because they had Skype there
nearby, and so they have a lot
of ex-Skype people who are
investing into the ecosystem,
and they have accelerators, and
they have angel financing,
and they have venture
financing.
All of a sudden, you have all
these cool companies coming
out of this tiny little country
in the Baltics.
So I think it's just success
begets success.
The world is flattening
a little bit.
It's not flattening as much or
as quickly as we would like.
Angel List, we can be helpful,
but frankly, the bar is higher
if you're outside of Silicon
Valley or New York.
You've got to show a
lot more traction.
It's a rare venture capitalist
who's going to get on a plane
to fly to North Dakota.
I always though capital
was liquid--
AUDIENCE: If he was smart,
he would go there.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: By the way,
North Dakota is having its own
venture capital boom, it's just
around energy and shale.
But I always thought capital
was very liquid.
It turned out capital is liquid,
capitalists are not.
So capitalists don't like
to get on planes, and
they don't have to.
They're rich by definition.
So you've got to get on a plane,
you've got to come
here, you've got to open a
satellite office, you've got
to network a little bit.
You've got to use every resource
at your disposal
including Angel List, including
YC, including
whatever you can get to.
And I would say 10 years ago, it
was nearly impossible, with
the occasional exception,
to raise money
outside of Silicon Valley.
That's changing.
So now it's probably about
half the activity is in
Silicon Valley and maybe
half is spread out over
the rest of the world.
So that's a lot better than it
used to be, and that's thanks
to the internet, that great
equalizer that brings us all
here today.
DON DODGE: Great.
Thank you.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's Billy and I have
a question of all of you,
especially for Jessica.
I watched videos of you in Y
Combinator last year where you
talked about the Pokemon monster
for the startups.
DON DODGE: Pokemon--
AUDIENCE: The monster
for the startup.
JESSICA LIVINGSTON: Do
you mean my talk
on what goes wrong?
AUDIENCE: No.
You talked about all the
challenges for the startups in
the YC class last year.
JESSICA LIVINGSTON: Yeah,
[? Mino ?] monsters?
AUDIENCE: It doesn't matter.
So my question is for you, one
of the challenges for all the
people who want to start up here
is a lot of us are on H1B
visa, and I know a lot
of talented people.
They are very highly
motivated.
But because of the constraints
of the startup visa, they
cannot go out and start
their own company.
So I want to know, how does
the startup community in
Silicon Valley deal with
this, and how much the
progress are we making?
And if we cannot make any
progress in the short term, do
you have any advice for anyone
on H1B visa but want to go out
and start their own company?
So
JESSICA LIVINGSTON: Just so I
make sure I understand your
question, it has to do with
immigration rules and how hard
it is to come here and
start a startup?
I know a lot of people care very
much about this topic.
AUDIENCE: And how do we
make progress on this?
JESSICA LIVINGSTON: People,
I promise you-- not me
particularly, even though I
worry about it a lot because a
lot of the people we fund are
from other countries--
but I know that a lot of heavy
hitters in Silicon Valley are
spending a lot of time trying to
make changes with the visas
and that sort of thing.
What I've noticed from the
people we funded, they can
come to Y Combinator for three
months, but it's very
difficult because they'll have
to fly back right before Demo
Day and they might not get back
into the country, and I
know it's very difficult and
challenging for them.
AUDIENCE: I'm talking about the
people who are in Silicon
Valley or residing
in the US here.
JESSICA LIVINGSTON: OK, I'm--
AUDIENCE: Still on the H1B,
because of the H1B visa
constraints, they cannot
go out there and
start their own company.
JESSICA LIVINGSTON: They can't
start a startup because
you're on an H1B?
AUDIENCE: Yes, exactly.
JESSICA LIVINGSTON: Maybe try
to get a different visa?
An O1?
DON DODGE: There are other
ways to do it.
JESSICA LIVINGSTON: There
are other ways.
I mean honestly, I'm probably
not the best person to give
advice on that.
I would talk to either other
people who have started
startups and have gotten
different visas or an
immigration lawyer.
DON DODGE: So Steve Case,
the founder of AOL,
is working on this.
Ron Conway is working on it.
Google is working on it.
We're trying really hard to
solve this problem, but it's
not an easy one.
It's going to take
a little time.
But believe me, people are
working hard to fix it.
HEIDI ROIZEN: One way to stay in
the country is get accepted
into a Ph.D. program
somewhere.
I'm serious.
Get accepted into
a Ph.D. program.
AUDIENCE: My other point would
be apply for Startup Chile and
get $40,000.
They give you the visa
on top of it.
DON DODGE: If you want to
go Chile, that's great.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: It struck me as funny
what you said about
dropping out of school.
What are your views
towards education?
I mean, if I were a 10-year-old
boy who wanted to
be an entrepreneur when I'm an
adult, what you think I should
be learning to become
an entrepreneur?
What would be a university
program to become an
entrepreneur?
HEIDI ROIZEN: First of all,
education is changing, and the
role of education,
higher education.
I mean, there's massive stuff
on that, and I won't go into
it except to say I'm the parent
of one college age
student and one person applying
to college, and I'm
still strongly encouraging them
to go to college and get
their degrees.
And I teach at Stanford, where I
strongly encourage people to
get their degrees because
for better or worse--
first of all, Stanford has a
pretty good filter and so many
of things that apply talking
about accelerators, talking
about going to a higher
institution of
education like Stamford.
And also, I believe the degree
is a driver's license, and it
is a minimum criterion for
certain things and for certain
places, and it helps you.
I have a few degrees from
there and it helped me.
Stay in school, kids,
if you can.
A little bit of the problem is
some of the very smartest
people I know, school isn't for
everybody, and the lore is
you look around--
Mark Zuckerberg, and Bill Gates,
and Steve Jobs, and I
mean, the list there is quite
a few people like that.
But there are a couple people
who win the lottery every year
too, and that doesn't mean it's
a good strategy for you.
AUDIENCE: No, I already
finished school.
HEIDI ROIZEN: I think that there
are so many programs and
there are so many universities
now that understand that
entrepreneurship.
And when we say
entrepreneurship, that doesn't
even just mean founding
companies.
It also means being an
entrepreneur within an
environment, going to work for a
startup, understanding that.
That's what I teach.
I teach entrepreneurship,
but I really teach more.
It's almost like a
psychology class.
So I think you can go do that.
I think there are
many programs.
There are many undergraduate
and graduate institutions
where you can almost do your
entire startup working on the
startup and take classes.
And you take your marketing
class, and you take your
channel class, and you take your
financial modeling class,
and you just use them all to
work on your startup, and so
you could almost get a degree
kind of incidentally.
So I think those things can
happen and I would encourage
you do that, but I think there's
a tremendous amount of
material that's also
available online.
And particularly as it relates
to the business side of being
an entrepreneur, there's
a lot of material.
Again, Brad Feld has written--
he's been prolific about doing
books and being a great source
of material.
So if you go to feld.com and
poke around, you can find
other ways without having to
pay the expensive tuition.
I'd encourage you to look
at some of the Stanford,
particularly the Stanford MOOCs
that are going on this
summer because they're
all free.
DON DODGE: Heidi, this question
came up last year and
Paul Buchheit answered
the question.
He answered it this way.
The best training for
doing a startup is
to work at a startup.
So Paul worked at Google, so
he picked a good startup to
work with because there were
only just a few people there.
But truly, the best training for
starting a company is to
work at a startup.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Just to riff on
that, I think asking if you
should go to college or not, I
mean, it's highly contextual.
Don't go to the University of
Phoenix and end up in debt.
Do go to Stanford if
you get the chance.
So it does depend on your
opportunity cost, who you are,
where you are, what you want out
of life, and how much it's
going to cost you.
That said, I would say if you
want to be in this business,
learn technology.
Best case, get a CS degree,
double E, mechanical
engineering, math, something
like that.
If not, worst case, go to Code
Academy, spend 12 weeks, bury
your head, go to Block,
go to Code Monk.
Just learn the code, learn
design, learn the rudimentary
parts of it.
It's a little silly to be in
the business of technology
without understanding the
technology and the
tools are all there.
DON DODGE: Great.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: Having a successful
startup is really hard, and
you guys are in the business
of funding startups.
The success rate is very low.
After a few good exits, what
makes you stay in the game and
what makes you think you'll
have another great exit?
NAVAL RAVIKANT: I think to get
in the game in the first
place, you have to
be fundamentally
broken at some level.
I don't think success
fixes that.
[LAUGHTER]
JESSICA LIVINGSTON: I don't
know if I'm fundamentally
broken, but I'm maybe
a little crazy.
I just love working
with the founders.
I mean, every single day is
different and it's just so
exciting to be part of their
journey, especially when you
start with them so early on when
they get rejected over
and over and have so many
problems that they face and
they overcome them.
It's exhilarating.
HEIDI ROIZEN: As an older
member of the venture
community, I think that there
are no higher highs and no
lower lows than being an
entrepreneur, and I will never
be more proud of anything than
the work I did when I was an
entrepreneur.
But that's a lifestyle that
burns you out, and I did it
for 14 years.
And so at the end of that I
said, I really love this
stuff, but it's like being a
parent and then deciding,
maybe it would be easier
to be a grandparent.
You can hand them back
when the diaper
needs changing or whatever.
So I think that for venture, and
I know a lot of the people
that enjoy venture, they love
the thrill of the entrepreneur
and being with entrepreneurs
and doing fun, interesting
things, but in all honesty, they
just don't want to work
as hard and they don't
necessarily have that
passionate spark
to be intensely
driven to do one thing.
And so they go into this line
of work and this line of
work's pretty fun because you
get to be on the sidelines and
be helping, but you aren't
necessarily the one who's
having both those high highs
and those low lows.
DON DODGE: The other thing is
as an entrepreneur, you can
only do one thing.
You're heads down on one idea.
When you're an investor, you
can invest in 10 different
companies and live vicariously
through them and help them.
So most of the investors
that I know do it
because they love it.
They don't really do
it for the money.
They do it because they love it
and they love to help build
companies and build people
and do great things.
And they make money along the
way, too, but it's not the
driving force.
Ask Ron Conway about that.
He stopped working for money
about 40 years ago.
He does not need
any more money.
But no one works harder than he
does because he just loves
what he does, and most investors
are like that.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
My name is Taylor.
I'm from Costa Rica.
Down there, we have a lot of
smart people, a lot of great
ideas, but sadly, we don't have
a culture of investment
and startup accelerators,
something like that.
So I wanted to ask if you have
options, or do you offer
possibilities to companies from
outside of the United
States, and also if there are
any regulations or something
that might stop investors from
this country to give money to
companies in other countries.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: It's a
super hard problem.
There are regulatory issues, but
that's just one of many,
many, many issues.
Probably the biggest one is just
at a very early stage,
investing is a people
business.
And so you don't know the
people, you don't know the
network, you don't
know the culture.
You don't even know what
you don't know.
So it's very difficult to
invest in an early stage
startup that's overseas.
At Angel List, we do a bit
of overseas matching--
in fact, that's where I think
we add the most value-- but
generally, those companies need
to have a fair bit of
traction because that's
what it takes to
pull a remote investor.
And even then, it's pretty
rare and difficult.
So surprisingly to me, the way
that most international
companies get funded these days
is they actually move to
here, which seems backwards.
But actually, there are
accelerators that do nothing
but cream skim and import
from entire countries.
And it's a very valuable
service, but
that's what they do.
UpWest West does it from Israel,
and Startmate does it
from Australia, and there's
a Korean one, a
Japanese one, and so on.
DON DODGE: Seedcamp.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Yes, exactly,
Seedcamp from Europe.
So it's expanding.
It's getting better.
But the good news is, the great
liberator here is the internet.
Every year that goes by, online
transactions get a
little bit easier, the knowledge
gets a little bit
more distributed, remote working
and collaboration gets
a little bit further, and
companies that were trapped
geographically in one area can
suddenly address markets in
another area thanks
to the internet.
So I think it is improving,
but it's going
to be a long cycle.
It's not an overnight thing.
I'm a little pessimistic in
that I actually think the
internet will solve
the problem before
the politicians do.
I think the internet will get
there before the visas do.
DON DODGE: Great.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Marcus.
I'm from Brazil, but it has
been three months that I'm
living in Canada, and there,
we are working on an idea.
And we have the prototype, we
have the landing page, we have
a great team, but we
can't afford the
launching for many reasons.
So the question is,
what's next?
DON DODGE: What do you need to
see to fund the company?
So you've got the product,
you've get the
team, you've got--
AUDIENCE: We just can't afford
the launching for many
reasons, so what's next?
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Is it hardware
or software?
AUDIENCE: Software.
But we need servers
and everything.
We can't afford it if people
start to use it.
So how can we get funding before
launching the project?
NAVAL RAVIKANT: I mean,
the obvious thing is
just launch it anyway.
Come on, what? $250 Hiroku
server or AWS.
Just get something up there.
At least then you can start
talking to investors and
accelerators and people who
might be able to help you to
the next step.
And there are accelerators
in Canada.
You can apply to YC from there
as well, and maybe get down
here for an interview.
Drive across country
if you had to.
What was it, Brian Chesky, sell
cereal if you have to.
JESSICA LIVINGSTON:
Sell cereal boxes.
Sorry to interrupt you, Naval,
but you brought up and it's
sort of a funny story.
But certainly, you could
apply to Y Combinator.
If you can't do that, I've seen
lots of variations on how
to bootstrap.
I mean, if you can't charge
customers, the story from
Airbnb is that they
were destitute.
They could not pay for anything,
and they were
designers from RISD.
So it was around the
presidential campaign here and
they thought, OK, let's design
these kooky cereal boxes.
And they had Captain
McCain cereal
that was Captain Crunch.
Hopefully, you know
what that is.
And Obama Os that were
a take on Cheerios.
And they said, gosh,
let's see.
We'll make them a limited
edition and sell
them for $40 each.
And they made thousands and
thousands of dollars, and
that's not only how they paid
their rent, but they actually
wound up eating the cereal when
they couldn't afford to
go grocery shopping.
DON DODGE: The other answer is
the natural progression of
funding is your first money
comes from friends and family.
So the first $10,000 or the
first $50,000 comes from
friends and family, and
that gets you far
enough to get it launched.
And then your second money
comes from angels, former
entrepreneurs or angel
investors or
that kind of thing.
And it's only after that that
VCs will actually get involved
and give you even more money,
so start there.
HEIDI ROIZEN: But I'm going
to jump in on that.
First of all, don't take any
money from people who cannot
afford to lose it because as
much as you love it and as
much as your parents love you
or whatever, if people give
you money that they can't afford
to lose and you lose
it, I just think it's
a bad way to live.
So number one, that.
Number two, it's funny.
With all due respect to what
you just said, you're not
technical, right?
My undergraduate degree was in
creative writing, so there is
a future in technology even
for people who don't code.
I did code.
Nobody would want to buy my
code, but all you guys who
code and women who can code, you
need people like us to do
all that other stuff you
don't want to do.
So there's a future, even for
those of us who don't.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: To clarify,
my point was you should
understand the technology.
I don't write the code for Angel
List, but I at least
know a little bit of
what's going on.
HEIDI ROIZEN: And after this
many years in this business, I
know a little bit
about it, too.
But I will say this.
I'm not a technologist, but I
know some really simple math
about companies and ownership,
and there's only ever 100%.
It never changes.
You can't change it.
You can make the percentages
worth more, but you can't
create more.
So be very careful about
taking money
on by selling equity.
If you do that, you are diluting
your company, you are
setting up expectations, you
are putting people in a
situation of needing you to get
liquidity so that they can
sell the company or take it
public or whatever, and they
have limited time frames of how
long they're going to wait
to get that money.
So I just say that to say, try
to think about raising money
and imagining that none of
our categories existed.
And before our categories
existed-- because even venture
is a relatively new thing.
I mean, it certainly wasn't
around 100 years ago.
People made money these
kinds of ways.
They did consulting.
They did other products.
They worked on nights
and weekends.
They stole from their
employers.
I'm not recommending that,
clearly, but I'm just saying
there's all sorts of ways
that people get
companies off the ground.
And unfortunately, I think
what's happened, and
particularly here in
Silicon Valley--
I think it's one of the
downsides of being here with
all the positive things, is
everybody thinks the first
thing you do here is you get
money from other people and
you sell equity to do it.
And I would argue that's
actually not the greatest way
to start a company, and I would
look at all these other
ways to do it.
DON DODGE: OK.
We have four minutes left.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Email me.
You can guess my email.
AUDIENCE: OK. thank you.
DON DODGE: We have four minutes
left so we're going to
go into the lightning round.
That means you ask the question
15 seconds, and we
answer in about 30 seconds.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So my question is for
Jessica and Y Combinator.
I know last year, you announced
that you would be
accepting applicants from people
who didn't even have an
idea for a startup yet.
Was that successful?
What are you looking for in
people who have no idea?
And what have you learned
from the process?
JESSICA LIVINGSTON: Yeah.
That was called the No Idea
Track, and we thought, there's
a lot of smart, talented
people out there.
We should let them apply even if
they don't have an idea and
we can help them.
It wasn't the best experiment,
to be honest.
But that said, we funded a lot
of people who we didn't like
the idea that they applied with,
and we've worked with
them, and they have new ideas.
So we'll continue to fund people
without ideas, I think.
DON DODGE: Awesome.
Next.
AUDIENCE: I'm Victor.
I'm from Ghana.
Jessica mentioned earlier that
only 2% of the people that
apply get taken at
Y Combinator.
And you also mentioned that a
lot of people you fund are
from other countries, from
outside the United States.
And Naval mentioned that it's
difficult for you to actually
fund people who are not
based in America.
I come from Africa.
The problem is the
other way around.
You have a lot of people
who have ideas but
who do not have money.
Here, you have the money but
you don't have the ideas.
DON DODGE: You need
to ask a question.
AUDIENCE: Don't you think
there's something wrong with
the funding model here?
Don't you think you probably
need to scale it beyond the
shores of America because there
are people there who do
not have the expertise
but have the money.
They want to know
how to invest.
I've been on both sides
of the table myself.
I've lost money.
I've also been an
entrepreneur.
So what we do not have
there is knowledge.
Don't you think that
model should be
scaled beyond the US?
HEIDI ROIZEN: Yes.
I mean, I think it should.
But I think the point is if we
don't do it, it's because our
model is working here.
And I would argue that there are
actually a fair number of
ideas here, and part of the
reason is because all of you
are here in this room.
So just look around the room
and understand you all did
something to get here.
So this model is working for
this, but I think the model
needs to be more distributed
and it will over time, and
people will change that.
You've got to find the right
people to change it.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Think of
it as an ecosystem.
People are funding the animals
within the ecosystem to find
the things to eat.
If the ecosystem isn't there,
you can't fund the animals.
You can't fund the fish
in the desert.
We have to build the ecosystem
too, and that takes time.
DON DODGE: Thanks.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So in regards to what you said
about equity, what would you
recommend to give up
for investments
instead of an equity?
If you were put in a situation
between giving up equity or
being put in a perpetual
royalty, which would you
believe is more beneficial
to a company?
HEIDI ROIZEN: Never sign up for
anything that's perpetual,
I mean that doesn't
have an end.
So I mean, things that I think
you can consider doing, for
example, do a white label
version of the product for a
customer that is going to-- let
them exploit it all they
want, but don't give them rights
to future development
and don't give them rights to
resell it to other people.
One of these we did early on to
bootstrap our company is we
realized that we could
handle two byte code.
I know this is really ancient
history, I'm sorry.
Back in the '80s, CPM day,
anybody remember that?
And our biggest competitor
could not.
So even though they were much
bigger than we, we went over
to Taiwan, Japan, Korea.
We went places where two byte
code mattered and we did
basically countrywide site
licenses because we could sell
to one OEM and we could bring
in a couple hundred thousand
dollars and that could
fund the company.
We said, what are the chances
we're actually going to get
over to Korea in any
near term and be
selling directly to consumers?
It was like zero.
But everything should have an
end because someday, you're
going to want to sell your whole
company and you need to
be able to own the rights to the
core of what you're doing.
Because I've also seen
developers do this where
they'll say, fund me and I'll
give you a 10% royalty for the
rest of my life on the product,
and they create
unfundable companies.
DON DODGE: All right,
last question right
here in the red shirt.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
I'm from New York.
So you mentioned about
college dropouts.
So I'm working with two lovely
ladies who are professors from
New York and they're
past their 40s.
So what do you think about
age and startups and that
collision, because so
far, it's targeting
the 20 years old.
DON DODGE: So age,
does that matter?
AUDIENCE: Yeah two co-founders
in their 50s, not dropouts.
HEIDI ROIZEN: Neither
young nor old.
I mean, there could
be brilliant
people who are young.
If anything, I think the
problem around here is
everybody thinks if you're too
old, you must not have
anything good you can do.
I think that there are some
generational differences and
age doesn't matter
to me at all.
It's about what you
know how to do.
AUDIENCE: They are
not as agile.
They cannot move.
They have other
responsibilities.
But OK.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: I would give
them every bit of success,
perceived or actual, for
five years back.
DON DODGE: All right.
I'm sorry, we have to end.
We're out of time.
But thank you all very
much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]